it's a big week in video games big
because a lot of big companies are
sharing big plans at a big convention &
big because a lot of people travel on
big trips to get there see the big news
in person that's why I'm here Chris
waters and Lucy's there it games come
Microsoft kicked things off on tuesday
with their press conference in which
they shared a lot of interesting info
over the course of about 90 minutes i
bet i can do it into quantum breaks time
powers break when these time cops break
onto the scene and it looks cool mayor
Carcetti aka little finger looks to be
the bad guy in the show and in the game
and the game in the show are coming
April fit scalebound gameplay tell the
dragon what to do and do dragon stuff
when you turn into a dragon man or
should I say dragon bro Master Hunter
meets DMC with four player co-op cool
coming in 2016 apparently bold claim of
the week goes to crackdown 3 with a
hundred percent destructible
environments oh really check time top 10
Tallyho one xbox one DVR for
over-the-air TV to chat pad 3 backwards
compatibility launching in November or
with over 100 games five windows 10 also
coming in november six with windows 10
streaming exponent pc-7 and cross by
crossfade cross play for some eight
special halo 5 Guardians Council 9 and
controllers 10 uh no 10 killer toad
brings killer kicked two killer instinct
two day season 3 coming in March Koji
gets cross play his blood-stained is an
idea decks Fox title just like train
simulator worms WMD and using balloon
animals with corpses aka thimble weed
puppy Xbox one has a line on city
builder city skylines and Xbox game
preview aka early access aka play this
game before it's done is getting
sheltered our survival of all starbound
and we happy few to name a few more than
a few Brody humanoids in the dark souls
3 gameplay trailer and also a giant
skull King Oh more than a few grody
humanoids in the FIFA 16 trailer but you
never hear me say that out loud because
it's not nice Just Cause 3 drank far
cry's milkshake and proclaimed itself
the Lord of all video game mayhem and I
for one and ready to swear fealty
homefront the revolution is a game about
doing terrorism because your kid doesn't
like public speaking not really it's
darker and more oppressed but still with
a lot of terrorism I want to care about
anything in my life as much as turn 10
studios cares about realistic puddle
modeling for ports of motorsports six
but i'm afraid that much
motion you can shoot guys in a boat you
can wear a German coat would you like to
use a gun nails or bullets either one
shoot it and try not to miss shoot and
win in Rainbow six siege and the grand
finale Kabam Oh announcement halo wars 2
and development by the total war
developers an interesting development
indeed and that's just the start
gamescom news all week with more
gameplay more demos more trailers more
interviews more stories more video games
for all y'all who love video games so
what was your favorite from the
Microsoft press conference mine was
quantum break cool time powers the story
is really intriguing let me know what
you think in the comments below or find
me on Twitter at CT waters see you
around
you